taiwan walker joining the team and he'll
make his blue jay debut tonight
his sixth start of the season and he has
gone seven innings twice and six
innings in another start so that's one
thing the blue jays would really like to
see
from him tonight and a ground ball down
to third
teles will get back to the bag and
plenty of time to throw across the
infield from
shaw and no damage done to walker in his
first inning as a blue jay
alex cobb's numbers this year six starts
uh pretty impressive
three seven three earned run average 22
punch-outs does have the 10
walks but uh 27 hits is nice keep it
under the innings pitch
there goes teles and the 3-2 is lined
into right field for a base hit
bobbled out in right and now tolez is
going to break for third and be in there
the throw gets away rowdy will stay at
third hernandez got to second on the
play as the orioles throw it around
and it all started with a line drive to
the opposite field by t
oscar hernandez we'll wait and see how
it scored either way it's second and
third
as guerrero lashes the ball to left
field and off the fence on the fly
and this will score a couple of runs on
a rocket
of a single by vladimir guerrero and the
blue jays lead early
rowdy celeste walked with two outs t
oscar gets a single
and then blatty hammers his knuckle
curve ball off the wall in left field
vladimir guerrero is starting to heat up
folks and this
is a rocket peles can jog in right
behind him here comes te oscar
and vladie guerrero has just extended
his history
taiwan walker with his first lead as a
blue jay goes back to work
well what a good job by walker he comes
all the way back from a 3-0 count to
strike out chance
cisco it's his first strikeout of the
ball game but he fell behind 3-0 and
just kept pounding that strength soon
and
throws a good sinking fastball right at
the bottom of the zone
look at that slider hard breaker down
and in under the hands of ruiz
and a very nice second inning for taiwan
walker
this is gretchen hit well to right field
off the wall
didn't get out this time santander throw
to second
and they got him santander
fires it in iglesia supplies the tag and
that's one way to get grichik out let
him hit the wall and throw him out at
second base right
absolutely so first and third nobody out
and here's derrick fisher
and the fastball swung on hit sharply to
second
dropped they'll get the out there the
out
is recorded at second but fischer will
reach on the fielder's choice
guerrero will score there will be no
error on the play
because you can't assume a double play
but again it's another play that's got
to be made
blue jays have asked for the review of
the call at second on the force out
yeah they call him out huh that's a hard
one to return i guess
because it was in his glove now let's
see if biggio can pick up
these two runners here but the two out
base hit and the 1-1 slash down the left
field line and down for a base hit
and the score is fisher panic in behind
him
and it is five to nothing
for another great swing by calvin biggio
he got that splitter away after a couple
of fastballs
and vizio delivers another double that's
his eighth double
cashes in fisher and panic
taiwan walker making his blue jays debut
tonight he's qualified for the victory
and he's out to start the sixth
battling back from a 3-0 count and
eventually on the 3-1
pitch a lazy fly ball to right one down
the 2-0
ground ball towards the middle ranging
off to his left it's speared by shaw
from his knees throw to first in time
travis shaw the third baseman
off on the second side of the bag up the
middle
able to range and he put it on the money
to ratty tolez to get the out
and there are two down here's ryan mount
castle
and he'll pop the first pitch up and
taiwan walker
is through six innings six scoreless
innings
91 pitches six shutout innings and you
can see he's a little more relaxed now
he got through his first blue jays start
in
fine fashion nothing wrong with six
scoreless innings in your first
appearance with a new ball club
as a.j cole comes on to work the eighth
inning
as iglesious goes around chasing a
slider down and away one down
and this is that slider that cole uses
so frequently
iglesias waves at it and then like did i
really swing at that pitch
if i don't move maybe they won't see it
yeah
and another strikeout for coal as he
gets nunez
cole has struck out the first two
batters he's faced here in the eighth
inning
to center field and grichik is right
there and it's a three up three down
eighth inning
for aj cole two balls no strikes to joe
panic
time giants infielder
pops it up left side ruiz
long way to go and made the catch oh
what a play
with the shift i mean he had to run a
long ways
yeah that was a beauty right there
concentration
great feel for where it was and comes
down with a huge second out nice play
ruiz
wilmer font on to work tonight
to right field hernandez is there and
that's your ball game
the blue jays shut out an opponent for
the first time this season
four pitchers combined on a five-hitter
biggio drives in a couple tayoska
hernandez has a couple of hits
font finishes it off taiwan walker
terrific in his blue jay debut and but
they're three games over 500.